[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous ravis de vous
retrouver bienvenue dans saab au regard
des missions masqué vous le savez
contraint sanitaire oblige et puis aussi
pour l'exemple
au sommaire ce soir un symbole du combat
écolo le glyphosate dans les couloirs du
palais bourbon la date n'a pas été
oubliée malgré la crise sanitaire
emmanuel matheron s'était donné trois
ans pour en finir avec cet herbicide
toxiques trois ans roumieh la promesse
présidentielle ne sera pas tenue
pourquoi existe-t-il des alternatives à
cet herbicide dans l'agriculture et puis
faut-il légiférer la majorité est
divisée sur le sujet on en parle dans un
instant dans notre grand débat on
parlera aussi de ce documentaire
complotistes qui fait des ravages sur
internet hold up
près de trois heures de mensonges et
autres thèses conspirationnistes il
prétend démontrer que le virus est une
vaste manipulation des politiques et des
médias une députée de la majorité
témoigne dans ce film elle s'appelle
martin von heures doit elle démissionner
décryptage à suivre sur ce plateau enfin
notre grand témoin ce soit nous revient
avec une bande dessinée tempes
grisonnantes et moustache fournie il a
fait la route avec une illustratrice à
la recherche des éclaireurs du monde
d'après ça s'appelle les terrestre c'est
nom de ma mère c'est avec nous ce soir
voilà donc pour le programme hashtag cvr
n'oubliez pas tout de suite
place au débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir noël mamère bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous qu'elle production vous avez
reçu en juin dernier pour un livre sur
l'écologie pour sauver des vies et vous
publiez déjà donc aujourd'hui les
terrestre c'est un peu les mêmes
questions si l'on peut dire
une réflexion sur le monde de l'après
qu'ovide mais illustrer cette fois avec
l'illustratrice libanaise
raphaël macarons vous êtes allés à la
rencontre de ceux qu'on appelle les
collabos log
vous nous direz un petit peu s'il faut
prendre la fin du monde ou la fin d'un
monde je pense que vous préférez cette
expression mais on va d'abord débattre
de l'actualité et de cette promesse non
tenue je vous le disais dans le sommaire
promesses non tenues sur le glyphosate
promesse d' emmanuel macron bonsoir
julien aubert nous semons merci d'être
daf des députés les républicains de
vaucluse vous connaissez bien en ces
questions liées à l'agriculture
notamment à cause de votre
circonscription qui est riche en
maraîchage on en parlera peut-être nous
sommes aussi en duplex via skype avec
christian huyghe de l'inra et directeur
scientifique de l'institut national de
la recherche agronomique et
environnementale bonsoir monsieur et une
députée de la majorité porte parole du
groupe
lrm marie-christine verdier joucla va
nous rejoindre dans quelques minutes
enfin bon soir stéphane bonsoir myriam
bonsoir à tous mes fans bakowski qui
m'accompagne comme chaque soir avec son
billet d'actu pour ouvrir ce premier
débat si j'ai bien compris tout de suite
si j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai
bien compris ce soir myriam le président
macron doit certainement regretter un
tweet qu'il a publié il ya bientôt trois
ans c'était le 27 novembre 2017
l'union européenne venait d'autoriser
pour cinq ans de plus l'utilisation du
glyphosate est alors la pression
maquereau a pris son téléphone tu sais
que je vais faire quelque chose et il a
twitté en dix ans contrairement aux
autres pays de l'union européenne la
france l interdire l usage du glyphosate
dans un délai de trois ans maximum c'est
à dire avant le 27 novembre 2020 bon
alors le problème c'est que la date
arrive et qu'on sait d'ores et déjà que
la promesse ne sera pas tenue puisque
l'année prochaine on utilisera encore du
dif aux dates en france lady manuel ma
course était vite rendu compte 1 qu'il
ne pourrait pas tenir cette promesse
il a vite tweets et puis ça s'est vite
rendu compte qu'il ne répète pas du tout
été puisque dès 2019 bas lors d'un débat
citoyen dans la drôme en répandant une
simple question sur qu'est ce que vous
pensez du glyphosate
il disait que les promesses ne serait
pas tenu enfin cette promesse ou en tout
cas pas certainement dans les délais à
bas qu'il avait prévu et nous on a dit
on fera tout pour sortir en trois ans
maintenant est ce qu'on peut dire y aura
plus du tout de glyphosate dans trois
ans impossible si je vous disais ça
c'est simple je tue complètement
certaines filières alors cependant on
peut dire que le grade est oui et en
être que nous par se dire que après
blond le dit on le répète aux électeurs
un les promesses n'engagent que ceux qui
les écoutent bon et en même temps un
président qui ne tient pas ses promesses
ça fait toujours un peu mauvais genre
alors heureusement comme vous le disiez
évidemment il ya quand même un recul
c'est barbara pompili que la semaine
dernière l'a souligné l a dit qu'il y
avait quand même recul des ventes de 35%
en 2019 si on voit la cour vous allez
voir c'est quand même un sacré
décrochage parce que on revient à un
niveau inférieur à celui d'il y a
10 ans ça c'est la partie à moitié plein
du verre mais il y avait même la partie
à moitié vide c'est à dire qu'on est
quand même très loin de l'interdiction
totale promise par le président il ya
trois ans 1
en fait la stratégie du gouvernement
c'est de l'interdire le glyphosate
uniquement que dans les cas où il ya une
solution alternative
or comme on a trouvé une solution
alternative uniquement dans la moitié
des gab à l'année prochaine
il ya 50% des usages du glyphosate qui
continueront d'être autorisée mais
l'opposition l'a tient là une occasion
en or pour pour s'opposer enfin pour
dénoncer cette promesse non tenue
similaire si les reproches ne venait que
de l'opposition mais ça serait un
moindre mal
le problème c'est que les reproches
viennent aussi de la majorité
alors je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
quand même un bout de temps c'était eur
2 min 7 en juin
il ya 54 membres de la majorité donc de
la république en marche qui avait publié
une tribune dans le monde pour dire que
eux ils plaidaient pour l'interdiction
du glyphosate donc depuis de l'eau a
coulé sous les convoyant voilà la
tribune le temps de l'eau un peu coulé
sous les ponts certains signataires ont
changé d'avis comme barbara conquis lit
par exemple qui est devenu ministre de
l'écologie mais il ya d'autres
signataires qui eux restent attachés à
l'interdiction du glyphosate c'est
notamment le cas de jean charcot la roi
qui est député de l'isère qui
responsable de l'écologie pour grouper
les rues m qui lui a rédigé après une
proposition de loi pour interdire enfin
pour inscrire dans la loi l'interdiction
du glyphosate vous croyez que cette
proposition de la des chances d'aboutir
à peut-être reprise par par le groupe
majoritaire
alors si vous me demandez mon avis ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup mais enfin c'est
quand même à christophe castaner qui est
président donc du groupe la république
en marche de prendre cette décision
or en 2010 8 ch pas si vous vous
souvenez encore une fois mais christophe
castaner avait un autre poste c'est
toujours à la république en marche il
était délégué général c'est-à-dire
patron de la république en marche et à
l'époque il avait fait des promesses aux
familles des victimes du glyphosate
on les écoute je veux dire à toutes les
familles de celles et ceux qui seraient
touchés par le glyphosate
notre engagement est clair notre
promesse d'en sortir en 2020 est intacte
nous avons promis de sortir du
glyphosate dans trois ans nous en
sortirons alors est ce que christophe
castaner est toujours un adversaire
aussi acharnée du glyphosate
évidemment c'est loin d'être certain bon
à la question qui se pose c'est bien de
savoir
la majorité peut rester crédible sur la
question de l'écologie alors qu'elle ne
tient pas ses promesses
merci stéphane messieurs vous me
permettrez dire d'aller voir directement
la députée de la majorité qui nous
attend duplex bonsoir marie-christine
verdier joucla vous êtes porte parole du
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée la
majorité at elle perdu toute crédibilité
en s'asseyant sur cette promesse de
sortir en trois ans du glyphosate
moi je me rappelle très bien ce qu'a dit
le président de la république simplement
aujourd'hui on ne reprend uniquement la
première phrase il a dit qu'on sortirait
du glyphosate
à condition de ne laisser personne au
bord de la route et ç'a toujours été ce
qu'il a dit après on peut faire des
coupes et le second leg partie des
députés qui ont voté qu'un botté contre
l'interdiction du glyphosate contre
l'inscription de l'interdiction du
glyphosate parce qu'on a tenu cette
promesse et cette province on compte
bien la tenir après on a des choix à
faire c'est comme tout comme partout les
choix à faire c'est quoi c'est un de
vérifier que depuis qu'on a fait cette
promesse les choses ont évolué ce qui
est le cas vous l'avais dit il ya une
pièce c'est vraiment très sensible de la
vente des du glyphosate ensuite ses
devoirs ou en année par rapport à la
recherche quels sont les moyens qu'on a
mis au niveau de la recherche pour
arriver à accompagner tout le monde et
pour sortir définitivement du glyphosate
moi je vous prends dans le cas de la
viticulture
je suis présidente du groupe d'études
ligne vu nos logis à l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui au niveau des
mines iob vous n'avez pratiquement plus
de glyphosate qui est utilisé entre les
roms mais on a un problème sous le rang
sous leur or aujourd'hui les robots de
peuvent pas y aller où on n'a pas de
main d'oeuvre pouvoir désherber à la
main et c'est le seul cas où aujourd'hui
les viticulteurs peuvent encore utiliser
le glyphosate
donc je vous dis ce soir avoir la
solution fait une question vous nous
dites ce soir c'est une question de
faisabilité pas de volonté politique ce
gouvernement veut bien sortir quand on
ne sait pas maintenant mais feu sortir
d'ici j'imagine la fin du mandat des
manuels macron de ce glyphosate toxiques
mais bien sûr et le plus rapidement
possible mais à condition de ne laisser
encore une fois personne au bord de la
route vous savez il faut changer de
comportement quand on change de
comportement
la loi ne règle pas tout or moi je suis
désolé mais les agriculteurs les
viticulteurs ont prouvé qu'ils étaient
aussi dans cette démarche donc je veux
dire on y est presque mais on ne peut
pas non plus faire comme si du jour au
lendemain on pouvait ne plus du tout
utilisé on est tous conscients du danger
de cette de cette utilisation en fait je
veux dire ne trouverez pas un seul
député qui vous dira qu'il est pour
aujourd'hui il faut continuer à mettre
de l'argent dans la recherche et gale
ann c'est ce qui a sorti quand même un
rapport il ya une commission de députés
qui se réunit pour faire le suivi
justement depuis qu'on a pris cet
engagement pour voir comment les choses
vont avancer
il ya tout ça qui va être rendu public
et à partir de là on pourra remettre des
échéances j'éprouvais assuré qu'au
quotidien
les acteurs eux mêmes sont conscients de
ça il ya un principe de réalité
noël mamère et oui facture l agriculture
dans certaines zones géographiques
notamment il ya la question des pentes
et à la question de l'agriculture de
conservation on ne pouvait pas tenir
cette promesse raisonnablement alors il
ne fallait pas la formule est ici on ne
pouvait pas la tenir et contrairement à
ce que dit cette député de la majorité
ce n'est pas dès ce ne sont pas des
comportements qu'il faut changer c'est
le modèle car le glyphosate il faut
jamais oublier qu'il est associé un
autre modèle d'agriculture qui a montré
ses dégâts c'est les ogm puisque la même
société qui fabrique le glyphosate le
roundup bailleur monsanto c'est elle
aussi qui fabrique les ogm qui résiste
au roundup
donc on est dans un système qui est
complètement fou et dont on doit sortir
dont les beaucoup le d'agriculteurs sont
aujourd'hui les prisonniers
donc l'idée c'est pas de les montrer du
doigt et de dire que ce sont des
criminels de l'environnement l'idée
c'est de les aider à sortir de ce modèle
là en effet le glyphosate comme les
néonicotinoïdes comme un certain nombre
de ces pesticides qui empoisonne
l'environnement qui empoisonnent les
agriculteurs qui empoisonnent notre
santé ils sont l'expression d'un modèle
agricole dont il faut sortir et j'ai
justement en ce moment
discutent de la réforme de la politique
agricole commune de la pac et que les la
france va se voter un certain nombre de
budgets
c'est maintenant qu'il faut s'orienter
vers aider ceux qui veulent sortir
progressivement de cette dépendance les
aider à le faire et quand on regarde les
chiffres on voit bien qu'en effet les
aides apportées à l'agriculture
intensive qui se sert assez massivement
de ces outils pesticides cette
agriculture là est beaucoup plus et des
beaucoup plus défendu que l'agriculture
biologique est comme moi aussi je suis
de la gironde et je connais bien le
problème de la viticulture
cette dame nous dit quand même un
certain nombre de contre-vérités oui il
y a en effet en gironde un certain
nombre de viticulteurs qui s'inscrivent
dans la viticulture qui est plutôt bio
encore que ce soit pas facile à le faire
mais l'agriculture la viticulture dans
le bordelais ici je vous rappelle qu'en
gironde les cancers du cerveau sont
trois fois et demi supérieur à la
moyenne nationale
portage d'ailleurs à vous montrer tout
sur le passage au bio est sur le coup à
la fois financer mais aussi physiques et
mécaniques j'écoute le plus cher est
l'abandon ce tu cours de cet herbicide
dans l'opposition que dit la droite au
fond l'erreur c'était de se lier les
mains avec un calendrier mais quand on
regarde la france n'est pas de loin le
plus mauvais élève
la france a pesé à bruxelles notamment
pour que cette interdiction passe de 10
à 5 ans c'est déjà ça m'en a déjà maille
il ya deux points il ya un premier débat
sur le fond puisque moi je pense si vous
voulez qu'on a instrumentalisé le sujet
du glyphosate qu' une partie des agences
n'avaient pas conclu au caractère
cancérigène qui avait un débat
scientifique là dessus et qu'ensuite
quand vous prenez un céréalier qui m'a
kg de glyphosate sur un terrain d'un
hectare
c'est à dire ceux 40 mille tonnes de
terre en réalité ça revient à faire pipi
dans la mer s'ils voulaient se faire en
termes de rapports de volume donc si
vous voulez on a on a présenté le
glyphosate en lui-même comme le diable
bon je dis pas si vous voulez que la
tendance de l'agriculture ne doit pas
être progressivement d'éliminer des
choses qui effectivement avait sept
agents sur neuf aussi qu'ils disent que
non bon donc un moment donné faut pas
raconter n'importe quoi si vous allez
sur le fond deuxièmement tout ça n'a pas
été chiffré je vous donne quand même un
chiffre la sncf va mettre ses milliards
d'euros pour rénover les petites lignes
le coût du gdir est liée à l' os dédié
au désherbage des lignes du fait de la
disparition du glyphosate ses 600
millions d'euros
il faut expliquer je rappelle aussi aux
gens d'ailleurs que le glyphosate il
n'est pas utilisé sur les cultures et
utiliser n'importe quel agriculteur
l'utilisera avant n'est ce pas pour
avant s'ils voulaient de planter
plusieurs semaines avant donc si vous
voulez on a en a il ya un premier
mélange sur le fond ensuite il ya
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
dommageable la parole publique
c'est la volonté de faire du symbole
parade tweets sans réfléchir sans avoir
forcément des études pour voir la
faisabilité et ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on le fait je vous rappelle que
du temps de l'ancien un mandat françois
hollande quand dont emmanuel macron
était l'un des conseillers
on avait un ministre qui avait affiché
50% de nucléaire sans essayer de se
demander comment c'était faisable en dix
ans et puis piteusement après on arrive
en disant ben finalement l'objectif
étant inatteignable nous allons déplacer
l'objectif si on veut que les français
adhèrent à l'écologie d'abord il faut
l'asseoir sur vous avait parlé ensuite
des ogm
je pense qu on mélange tout elle tenait
non puisque c'est con parce que s'ils
voulaient parce que
mais pas nier que monsanto a mis au
point un ogm résistants je veux dire non
je ne joue pas alors mais ce que je vous
dis aussi c'est qu'aujourd'hui et manger
des ogm comme vous manger des produits
oblige aux hot
parce que quand vous importer du blé dur
du canada ou pour faire mûrir les blés à
cause d'un hiver y larguent des tonnes
de glyphosate pour accélérer le
mûrissement des blés et bien votre
système est quelque part contradictoire
parce que quelque part vous interdisez
sur le territoire français ou européens
dans le cas du lift aux athées des ogm
et ensuite nous fait manger à nos
concitoyens des produits dont on ne
maîtrise pas l'original est disposée
pour ça qu'on va essayer de savoir
rapidement mais l'autre notre by aubert
notre collègue mon ancien collègue
monsieur aubert nous dit que les agents
seront dit que le le glyphosate n'était
pas cancérogène on a quand même
découvert à travers les articles du
monde et de ce groupement de
journalistes à travers ce qu'on a appelé
les monsanto l'x que la plupart de ses
positions des agents s'étaient inspirés
directement par monsanto dont il faut
aussi faire très attention à ce qu'on
dit quand on cite les agences
il ya un an seulement l'agencé
européenne des aliments mais il ya aussi
lippé américain le ministère le
ministère de l'environnement
il est également l'agent chimique dont
on a montré qu'ils étaient sous
influence de vent sont alors je voudrais
avant de libérer
marie christine vernay jock là vous
redonner la parole parce qu'au fond
c'est vous dans la majorité qui allait
oui décider de l'avenir de cet herbicide
il y a une division au sein du groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée nationale vous
avez des députés comme monsieur cola roi
pour le site et qui veut aller jusqu'au
bout et qui dit eh bah tant pis si on ne
tient pas cette promesse je légifère et
je propose une proposition de loi pour
en sortir définitivement inscrire
l'interdiction dans la loi votre et ce
texte mais nous avons tous fait cette
promesse il ya trois ans moi je voudrais
quand même rappeler que c'est grâce à la
france que l'europe n'a reconduit le
glyphosate que pour cinq ans au lieu de
dix ans nous on a été mieux disant en
disant que ça serait trois ans on met
tout en oeuvre aujourd'hui pour y
arriver je veux répondre à monsieur
mamère à lui disant que moi quand je me
promène dans
vignes de mon vignoble gaillacois je
suis fier de me balader dans ce milieu
là parce que je vois les efforts qu'ont
fait les viticulteurs et en fait nous
avons actuellement l'étude dans
l'hémicycle 2 du projet de loi de
finances ou le gouvernement va déposer
un amendement pour reconduire le crédit
d'impôt pour le bio est que moi même je
vais défendre un amendement qui va être
validée par le gouvernement pour
reconnaître la certification haute
valeur environnementale de niveau 3 qui
va permettre d'avoir les crédits d'impôt
pour aider tous les agriculteurs pour
aider tous les viticulteurs à les
données fondées sur milan je maintiens
d'environnement et c'est votre droit
mais vous n'avez pas répondu madame
verdi joucla si un texte de la majorité
étaient sur la table pour interdire le
glyphosate vous de voter ou pas oui ou
non vous êtes porte parole du groupe à
part à partir du moma à partie alors là
je vais répondre à titre personnel je
vais pas répondre au nom du porte
parolat on est bien d'accord mais à
partir du moment où je serai sûr qu'il y
aura tout ce qui sera mis en oeuvre pour
accompagner les personnes et que
personne sera au bord de la route oui je
le voterai s'est dit merci beaucoup
merci d'être intervenu dans dans cette
émission je sais que vous devez regagné
l'hémicycle pour pour la séance
j'aimerais maintenant m'adresser aux
chercheurs que vous êtes christian
huyghe qui peut se passer aujourd'hui
pour bien comprendre du du glyphosate
quels types d'agricultures alors en
france quand on regarde à quoi le
diffuseur est utilisé il n'est pas
utilisé sur des ogm il est utilisé pour
la gestion des intercultures à dire ce
qui se passe entre deux entre deux
cultures de rente et pour gérer les
couverts en arboriculture et en
viticulture et donc le retrait des
autorisations de mise en marché se fait
dans le cadre d'un règlement européen
très précis le 11 07 2009 qui dit qu' on
peut retirer une autorisation de mise en
marché à partir du moment où il existe
des alternatives d'usagé courant sans
impact économique majeur et de ses toute
l'analyse qui a été faite sur les
substitutions à se sont faites dans ce
cadre-là existe-t-il des choses d'usagé
courant et quel est l'impact économique
il faut le chiffrer après c'est aux
politiques de décider si l'impact qu'il
est majeur mais faut d'abord qu'on
sépare le chiffre est donc ça conduit en
fait à identifier toutes les zones où il
existe des alternatives est
effectivement toutes situations où il ya
soit un labour soit un travail profond
du sol il ya une capacité à détruire
le couvert en viticulture il ya une
capacité à gérer l'intérêt commun géré
le pied durant vous pose une question si
je peux dire en plein alors dans la
bosse là où on a des immenses champs
on n'a pas besoin de glyphosate s'il ya
des alternatives non alors si vous êtes
en dans la beauce mais que vous
pratiquez l'agriculture de conservation
c'est à dire un endroit où on ne touche
jamais le sol rez et bien par
construction sasson l'agriculture de
conservation n'a été construit parce que
il existait une modalité chimiques de
destruction découvert donc à partir du
moment où vous n'avez plus la chimie
vous avez un souci par rapport à la au
cahier des charges tel qu'il a été
défini mais pour le reste si vous avez
des techniques culturales simplifiées
un travail mais relativement profond du
sol ou à la bourre de fait vous avez
d'autres modalités de destruction
c'est le cas la vraie impasse
aujourd'hui les vrilles impasse
aujourd'hui donc là où il n'existe pas
d'alternative
c'est le terrain on pense mais il y en a
quand même pas tant que ça et puis c'est
l'agriculture de conservation où on est
aujourd'hui à devoir faire une analyse
de d'équilibré entre les services que
rend l'agriculture de conservation en
particulier en matière de stockage du
carbone dans le sol et un effet
bénéfique sur le mode hiver le visage et
trèfle est en tête les quantités seront
plus faibles dans les grandes
les grands changements on a entendu dire
monsieur hubert donc les que non le ski
est en train de se doit d'être discutée
aujourd'hui et c'est le dernier texte
qui a été produit par lens s c'est 2
pour ces produits là qui sont maintenus
en agriculture de conservation c'est ont
fait baisser les doses homologuées et
donc pour le ce qui va se passer en 2021
les doses autorisées elles sont beaucoup
beaucoup plus basse que ce qui était
autorisé les quelques années je vous
propose si vous le voulez bien messieurs
qu'on se figurent les choses grâce au
reportage de clément mairie qui se
dresse le portrait de trois agriculteurs
face au dilemme du glyphosate et vous
allez voir la question de l'agriculture
de conservation on ne touche pas au sol
est au coeur d'un de ses trois portraits
reportages
un tracteur une charrue pour sébastien
guérineau la technique ancestrale du
labour reste aujourd'hui la principale
alternative aux clips hosatte mais elle
présente des inconvénients
on va dire que un coup de l'ifo je fais
un peu près de 15 hectares à l'heure et
la nuit un hectare à l'heure c'est
quinze fois plus de temps et puis ç'a un
impact sur la faune les vers de terre
par exemple n'aime pas trop la charia
parfois il est même préférable d'éviter
de la boule c'est le cas face à ces
jeunes chardon qui prennent la place des
céréales le labour les dissémine donc ça
envoie ses des pousses beaucoup plus
jeunes qu'on poussait la à l'automne
pour s'en débarrasser sebastian
guérineau n'a pas d'autre solution que
le glyphosate le seul produit
aujourd'hui vous permet de lutter
efficacement contre le chardon thibault
guilvert lui pratiquer une agriculture
différente qui cherche à préserver au
maximum la vie du sol fallu cette
agriculture dite de conservation capte
davantage de co2 mais paradoxalement il
lui faut plus de glyphosate
je sais pas combien on en utilise toi
mais ça peut être entre 40 et 80 sur
combien d'hectares sur 230
alors que moi sur 110 ha je suis un peu
plus de 200 litres
donc c'est le glyphosate venait à être
interdits ça voudrait dire que que je
revois tout le système entier quoi
aujourd'hui les seuls céréaliers à
produire son glyphosate sous les
agriculteurs bio
donc là en ce moment chez en train de
semer de la féverole donc c'est pour
l'alimentation animale et pas de
clausade pas de glyphosate taouli
fawcett
après sept ans en conventionnel valentin
au v a entamé sa conversion en bio pas
d'herbicides donc cela implique plus de
travail et d'importants investissements
matériels
n'essayez pas c'est vraiment le remake
plus gros problème avec un peu de
chardons donc forcément c'est plus de
passages de tracteurs ou plusieurs de
tracteurs
du coup ces rachats de matériel bineuse
hercé tri ou rotatives
si le travail manuel c'est reconnaître
des 100 détracteurs ce que le rumex
lalla hasnaa va appeler à plus de deux
mètres sur 2 mètres 50
pour sa deuxième récolte en bio valentin
ou v anticipe une baisse de rendement de
50 % qu'il compte compenser par des
cours plus élevés que dans l'agriculture
conventionnelle et anbar on le voit bien
dans ce reportage au fond sortir du
glyphosate ne va pas de soi quand on
fait du bio dont on désherbe à la main
c'est un coup c'est même un coup
physique oui c'est un coup et puis ce
qu'est ce qui aurait bien que par
exemple notamment de l'agriculture qui
fonctionnait la couverture des sols qui
pour moi est une écriture d'avenir même
si elle ne peut pas être fait par tous
mais je trouve que c'est très
intéressant comme démarche c'est dommage
parce que celle qui est impactée
ensuite votre reportage détermine par le
coup les italiens par exemple trop
besoin de beaucoup de blé pour faire des
pâtes
ils ont créé une filière de potes où il
vendait pas d'ailleurs deux fois plus
cher garantissant glyphosate donc
quelque part si vous voulez ils ont fait
de cette interdiction une source
d'augmentation de leurs marges en france
puis on est visiblement incapable de de
le faire sur d'autres à baggio qui
permet oui mais si vous voulez je pense
que le bio ça veut pas forcément dire on
pourra avoir un débat sur le bio un
parler de bouillie bordelaise d'autres
choses mais je crois que c'est pas
exactement la même chose
et puis on est ensuite je voulais dire
sur le sur les attaques sur les agences
attention aux discours je ne serai plus
là pour la suite de l'émission mais vous
allez avoir un reportage sur hold up et
sur un reportage qui met en doute la
parole publique on peut pas d'un côté
être horrifié
en disant regardez c'est terrible les
gens se passe finalement des vidéos qui
témoigne du discrédit de la parole et d
expertise et de l'autre pointe et les
agences de l'état en disant mais elles
sont dans nos mains et nos vies on
retourne et je peux retourner le
compliment est la meilleure qui tout à
l'heure nous a dit que le cicr qui
déclarait en 2015 que le défaut pour le
camp du non rick est une agence de
l'organisation des nations unies de l'om
faisait en 2015 que c'était un
cancérigène probable
il nous est dit oh boy tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord donc selon que l'on
veut une dizaine d'agents dont certaines
disent que c'est cancérigène d'autres
pans et de dire celles qui disent que ça
n'est pas cancérigène sont en vérité
comme ça j'ai dix ans je me sente au
travail
il ya un travail d'investigation d'un
groupe de journalistes internationaux
qui s'appelle les monsanto l'x qui a
démontré ce sont des arguments et des
facs des nous contourner pas le sujet au
magnifique news mais des familles
morizet effet contre lesquelles on ne
peut pas vous ai pas eu à lutter qui
montre que effectivement ces séances ont
été sur l'a12 hausse de monsanto et
notamment moi je vous ai envie de leurs
représentants étaient dépendants avait
des conflits d'intérêts mais moi je vous
ai jamais dit que le centre qui avait
déclaré que lui pose est était
cancérigène été payée par le lobby du
bio le lobby les écolos parce que c'est
pas le cas s'il est une agence à la
suite d'une autre manière de parler
changer aussi bien d'un côté quelque
chose qui est objectif qui est un fait
une photographie il ya ensuite quelque
chose de subjectif qui est d'expliquer
au monde
la différence de la photographie en
expliquant avec une thèse qui est
derrière ces deux manières d'aborder
derrière ce sont des faits les jeunes
gardes sont des faits c'est comme par
exemple ces journalistes d'investigation
qui a été poursuivi à coup de tweets
d'une manière absolument incroyable
après un reportage d envoyé spécial sur
le glyphosate ce n'était que des faits
il a reçu un prix au festival de berlin
au festival des reportages de berlin est
pendant ça n'empêche pour que ça n'a pas
empêché qu'ils soient poursuivis à coup
de tweets en disant qu'il mentait
jauger leur ordinateur qui était co
rapporteur d'un pas plus dangereux des
agents des séries fini sur les ogm
donc on s'est aperçu s'appelle séralini
bord dont on a vu à la fin qu'elle était
fausse et qui a servi de base à la
décision d'interdiction des ogm en
europe là ça vous gêne mon nom sur la
manière dont cela dans l'enceinte mais
on s'était plus s'il vous plaît parce
que au fond si on avait des alternatives
à toutes les formes d'agriculture on se
passerait toute volonté du glyphosate on
est d'accord sur ce point parce que je
pense qu'il y en a qui n'ont pas intérêt
à sa cause des systèmes de rendement de
7 à rappeler également que l'on me
trouve un produit qui fait la même chose
que le glyphosate et kénogami gas avait
des multinationales qui ont un tir qui
ont des intérêts liés aux énergies
fossiles puisque le roundup ça vient
laver vous avez bien expliqué et on a
entendu votre argumentaire sur lui pour
terminer ce débat au fond pourquoi la
recherche n'avance pas au fond assez
vite aussi vite que des mre l'opinion on
sait que le gouvernement s'apprête à à
financer davantage la la recherche faute
d'avoir pu tenir sa promesse 6 millions
sur la sur la table 6 millions d'euros
pour la recherche préciser nous vraiment
dans le détail quelles sont les
alternatives aujourd'hui est ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour arriver à en sortir
les interdictions mécaniques ont détruit
mécaniquement à couvert et donc ça
suppose que en amont ont des noms
construisons dès l'abord on définisse le
couvert végétal que l'on peut détruire
mécaniquement facilement en fait il faut
sortir de l'idée que l'alternative au
glyphosate c'est un autre produit
chimique un autre produit chimique qui
ferait comme le glyphosate aurait les
mêmes inconvénients pluie qui faisait
donc il faut modifier enfin partir de
l'objectif que l'on a à savoir gérer
l'interculture avoir un couvert végétal
que l'on met en place et donc c'est des
espèces qui ont des certain nombre
d'autres qui vont rendre des services
attendus et ensuite combinés à ça la
mécanique de le système de destruction
qui est obligatoirement une destruction
mécanique pour ne pas avoir un recours
avoir à courir un peu du chien
le chercheur monsieur huyghe
quand est ce qu'on aura ces alternatives
à votre année
vous savez sur ce genre de question on a
le on peut faire une expérimentation par
an c'est la réalité biologique des
choses vraies culturel assez propre
cycle et donc savalan de fait ça va
lentement ceci dit on n'a pas commencé
cette année c'est des choses les travaux
qui ont été commencées et quelques
années en particulier avec un certain
nombre d'associations qui font des
travaux sur l'agriculture de concerner
des déclas dix ans la recherche qui sont
prévues des crédits sur la recherche qui
sont étalés sur six ans ça veut dire que
pendant six ans on n'est pas sûr de
trouver encore une solution mais en fait
on va progressivement on se retrouve des
solutions qui sont de plus en plus
satisfaisante pour tout le monde et il
ya des configurations ou la destruction
mécanique marche très très bien et les
configurations elles marchent moins bien
une des grandes difficultés qu'on
rencontre en agriculture de conservation
pour une destruction mécanique c'est
quand couvert que l'on met en place et
hétérogène est dans une configuration
très particulière je veux juste vous
donner une illustration de cette
difficulté si vous avez un couvert qui
est très beau avec des moutardes et
facili des choses comme ça si vous avez
eu un passage de sangliers en plein
milieu de ça ils ont détruit le couvert
et au moment vous ne voudrez avec un
rouleau faca par exemple détruire par
roulage qui marche très bien et bien
l'endroit où les sangliers sont passés
ça se construit pas et vous aurez à ce
moment là une difficulté donc il faut
progressivement on va on va gagner un
sprint allemand du diesel avait un
pronostic ou pas notamment parce qu'il
faut que je ne fais jamais je ne fais
jamais de province est toujours là
l'intenable merci dans la tronche merci
beaucoup christian pycke d'avoir été
avec nous le temps de la recherche n'est
pas celui de la politique
en effet notamment sur ce dossier l'a
fait la recherche doit passeront on ne
doit pas chercher des solutions
techniques
on doit chercher des idées on doit
renverser le modèle actuel et donc aider
les paysans et les agriculteurs à
pratiquer cette transition qui doit être
une transition juste pour tous allez
vous rester avec no mercy stéphane comme
premier jour est qu'on s'arrête un
instant sur ce film sur la crise
sanitaire un film aux thèses
complotistes je vous le disais qui fait
le buzz autant qu'il dérange ça
s'appelle hold up
loin de nous l'envié d'en faire la
promotion ici temps richard et de
mensonge mais son succès en dit long il
interroge une députée je vous ai dit
qu'elle était de la majorité tout à
l'heure dans le sommaire autant pour moi
elle a été dans la majorité elle a
quitté aujourd'hui elle témoigne dans ce
film thomas des prêts nous décrypte tout
cela thomas oui exactement madame c'est
le film dont tout le monde parle ces
derniers jours en film aux thèses
complotistes qui dénonce de supposés
mensonges et de supposée manipulation de
l'état dans la gestion de crises
sanitaires mais alors que dit ce film
très exactement je vous raconte alors si
vous êtes présence sur les réseaux
sociaux vous n'avez pas pu passer à côté
le film s'appelle hold up
il a été publié sur internet mercredi sa
thèse principale le coronavirus a été
inventée par l'homme pour servir des
intérêts économiques
tout ce que le pays comporte d'élite et
mis en cause l'état
les journalistes les médias les
politiques mais également les
scientifiques le film dure deux heures
cinquante et flirte clairement avec le
complotisme comme cet extrait où la
sociologue de gauche monique
pinçon-charlot compare le coronavirus à
l'extermination des juifs pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale comme les nazis
allemands l'ont fait pendant la deuxième
il ya un holocauste qui va éliminer
certainement la partie la plus pauvre de
l'humanité c'est à dire trois milliards
500 millions d'êtres humains dont les
riches n'ont plus besoin pour assurer
leur survie
bonjour thomas husson bonjour travers
cette spécialiste du décodage des fêtes
news notamment pour le site space i
expliquez-nous ce film pourquoi ils
posent problème ce documentaire pose
problème parce que il dit pas grand
chose de vrai dissimule en fait ces
mensonges sont une espèce d'impression
de révélations c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît assez bien quand on travaille
sur les théories du complot ou le le
matériel complotistes on va superposez
tout un tas d'arguments qui n'ont
souvent rien à voir ensemble et qui vont
nous nous convaincre un petit peu nous
nous nous rentrer dans la tête
soit il ya d'autres éléments qui sont
que 1 et finalement on va porter des
accusations sans jamais apporter les
éléments qui permettent de porter ces
accusations et laissé planer une espèce
de doute comme ça et enfin et donne la
parole à des gens qu'on présente comme
de grands experts sérieux et qui sont
dans l'immense majorité des gens
totalement décrédibilisée dans leur
propre milieu alors ce film il prend une
tournure politique puisque
des élus ou des anciens et lui témoigne
dans ce documentaire l'ancien ministre
de la santé philippe douste-blazy mais
il a depuis pris ses distances avec le
réalisateur du film mais surtout la
députée liberté et territoires martin
rohner
elle est une adepte des coups d'éclat
ici dans l'hémicycle depuis le début de
la crise le masque ne sert strictement à
rien mesdames et messieurs pouvez vous
nous dire monsieur le rapporteur ou
peut-être monsieur le ministre
qu'est ce qui change d'une énorme grille
pain une fois de plus vous nous réunit
c'est afin d'attiser la peur et de
mettre à mal la stabilité de notre
république
ces déclarations elles ont forcément
fait réagir les députés notamment dans
le groupe majoritaire la république en
marche l'ancien ministre du numérique
mounir mahjoubi a demandé dans un tweet
la démission de martin bonheur nous on a
tenté de la contacter on lui a téléphoné
mais elle n'a pas répondu
[Musique]
voilà bien aimée pour être tout à fait
complet on a également contacté les
responsables du groupe de martin bonheur
qui est député liberté et territoires il
nous indique que pour l'heure il n'est
pas question de l'exclure et que sa
liberté d'expression est très importante
il nous indique également qu ils vont
quand même discuté avec elle pour
qu'elle les mette au courant de toutes
ses positions
merci beaucoup dans ma force au point
complet et noël mamère
que penser votre film est ce que vaut le
coup je n'ai pas vu ce film j'ai lu
beaucoup de choses autour de ce film
écoutez il est dans l'air du temps
le complotisme prospère face dans des
sociétés qui ne voit plus le futur qui
sont beaucoup plus complètement plongé
dans le brouillard de l'incertitude et
ce brouillard de l'incertitude il ne
fait que alimenter toutes les théories
complotistes
regardez ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
et qui a même franchi l'atlantique avec
le les complotistes de kyo hanon qui
sont d'ailleurs cautionnée par le
président sortant par trump ce film il
ne fait qu'aligner bénéficient notamment
pour sa production et pour sa promotion
je pense aux journalistes andré bercoff
il ya également la figure d g des jo de
maxime d'école
le nouveau françois rossi lien qui s'est
transformé en il y a dans ce pays comme
dans d'autres pays un certain nombre de
gens qu'ils soient des gilet jaune des
journalistes ou des soi disant experts
qui sont des relais privilégié du
complotisme est qui qui ne font que
finalement un style et un petit peu plus
à un poison qui est qui est un virus
aussi prospère que la copie de 19 mai
qui est un virus qui est en train de
miner et de rendre malade la démocratie
donc je pense qu'en effet il faut que
nous nous méfions de ce genre de film
parce que ce ne sera sans doute pas le
premier il y aura encore regarder
comment par exemple le professeur raoul
tu es devenu l'icône de tous ceux qui
pensent que il y à un complot derrière
les agissements du gouvernement les
réactions du gouvernement face à la
cohue vide donc je pense que tout cela
et est le symbole d'un air du temps
c'est le symptôme que ce soit en train
de vivre nos ça veut dire que notre ciel
symptôme d'une société qui est malade
sagascience de la confiance dans les
médias de la confiance dans la parole
publique et qui a peur de l'autre
regardez qu'est ce qu'on fait alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour lutter contre
la sarre fait c'est que d'abord on
garantit toutes les libertés qui sont
les nôtres aujourd'hui et qu'on ne fait
pas voter des lois de circonstances
comme celles qui se prépare sur la
sécurité globale avec notamment
l'immunité qui serait accordée aux
forces de police
mais c'était aussi et surtout lutter
contre l'ignorance et lutter contre
l'ignorance c'est le rôle des
journalistes c'est le rôle des
politiques c'est aussi le rôle des
scientifiques et des intellectuels de
contribuer date à dire que ce que l'on
voit par exemple dans ce film les
décodeurs du monde l'ont très bien
démontré à travers cet exemple qui sont
7 contre vérités qui sont exprimés dans
ce film la déconstruction et le travail
de détection équipe peut malheureusement
se faire une par lcp par des chaînes
dites traditionnelles
il devrait aussi se faire sur les
réseaux sociaux or pas de chance les
réseaux sociaux sont aussi le vecteur
est le moteur et le carburant du complot
la cpt bonheur martin von arx elle a
toujours sa place au sein du palais
bourbon
j'étais député j'ai pas mal ont décidé
elle est à partir d'un groupe c'est à
son groupe de décider de son avenir
alors on va parler maintenant cette
bande dessinée les terrestres illustré
par raphaël maccarone utile macarons qui
unit illustratrice libanaise
c'est aux éditions du faubourg c'est au
fond l'histoire de votre rencontre avec
7,7 jeune dessinatrice elle est écolo à
l'aîné au liban et vous rencontre voulu
parler d'écologie et vous décidez au
fond c'est tara reportage ces six
reportages d'aller à la rencontre de
ceux qu'on appelle les collabos log à
travers toute la france comment est né
ce projet déjà alors ce projet il est né
dans la tête de l'éditrice sofica ya des
éditions du faubourg qui est une jeune
maison d'édition et qui elle même a été
un petit peu ébranlé par toutes les
questions qui tournent autour de ce que
l'on appelle l'effondrement ou
l'accolade solo j elle connaissait mon
parcours politique l'intérêt que je
porte à toutes ces questions
elle m'a dit ça serait intéressant de
faire une série de reportages mais en
bande dessinée je lui ai dit écoutez moi
j'ai jamais fait de bandes dessinées
mais comme je suis journaliste de métier
et de traditions je suis toujours
curieux du neuf et donc elle m'a
présenté cette jeune illustratrice qui
est d'ailleurs une qui fait un travail
bien au delà d'illustration dans cette
bande dessinée qui s'appelle rafael
macarons et que j'ai amené dans cinq
lieux que j'avais comme matricielle en
passant par un autre lieu que nous avons
appelé la paille et le grain est un
couple avec deux enfants
l'idée de construire en hauteur avec un
chantier coopératif mais tous les lieux
que nous avons choisi qu'il s'agisse de
la ferme légère qu'il s'agisse de la
bascule sont pas des lieux de
survivalistes qui s'enferme it is
regroupe sur eux mêmes sont des lieux
qui sont en prise avec le milieu local
par exemple la famille qui est à côté de
la réole la réole a été très touché par
la crise économique
eh bien ils se sont intégrés dans la vie
locale et participa à des associations
pareil pour la ferme légère où ce sont
cinq couples de 19 à 60 ans qui
travaille beaucoup avec les paysans
locaux et notamment ce que l'on appelle
les paysans boulangers qui réhabilite
des farines ancienne que l'on avait
oubliée la bascule ce sont des jeunes de
votre
génération un peu plus jeunes qui
sortent des grandes écoles pour beaucoup
d'entre eux qui sont bardés de diplômes
et qui disent on veut pas continuer à
faire des boulots qui nous amène dans le
mur donc si on trie geek sa 100 édition
en réseau et ils essaient de céder à la
bombe
les lieux que nous avons que j'ai
choisie ou dans lesquels je suis allé
avec raphaël sont pas des lieux de la
collapse au logis oui la question de
l'effondrement et évoqué un certain
nombre de 1 chaque fois que nous y
allons mais c'est pas ce qui a conduit
ces groupes ces familles où ces couples
à changer de vie habiter la terre pour
la plupart des lieux de décroissance
non pas forcément c'est pas ça la
décroissance sont des lieux où comme le
dit le fruit le philosophe bruno latour
puisque mon titre les terrestre est une
référence directe à son livre ou
atterrir qui qui est un livre qui
explique qu' on ne peut plus parler des
terriens parce qu'on habite très mal la
terre mais qu'il faudra qu'il faudrait
devenir des terrestre c'est-à-dire qui
habite la terre autrement qui soit plus
respectueuse des autres des humains mais
aussi du monde non humains c'est à dire
tout ce qu'ils appellent notre entourage
si l'on veut préserver l'avenir de nos
enfants donc ces gens de croissance pour
vous cette question date décroissance
n'est pas forcément la solution à la
crise crée la 300 sel et la dent dans un
certain nombre de domaines déjà quand
vous assister à l'effondrement de la
biodiversité quand vous regardez par
exemple le dernier rapport du wwf qui
vous indiquent que durant les dix
dernières quinze dernières années
68% des mammifères des oiseaux ont
disparu 41% des insectes et 171 millions
d'hectares de forêts ont été atteintes à
la terre à la place à l'environnement
mais tout ça c'est dsk c'est la
diminution des ressources la ressource
beau on s'en va par exemple c'est une
ressource qui est en décroissance la
ressource en pétrole c'est une ressource
qui est en décroissance donc la
décroissance
elle est déjà la décroissance des
ressources des croissances de la
biodiversité
mais est-ce qu'il faut aussi la
décroissance pour lutter contre le
réchauffement
on se dit finalement est-ce que
l'innovation le progrès technique
croissance donc je pense à
ce qu on a en matière d'énergies
renouvelables par exemple ne sont pas
les solutions
j'ai finalement à sion n'a même pas
forcément le progrès humain c'est ce que
nous a saigné le professeur jacques
ellul qui avait écrit en 54 un livre qui
s'intitule la technical angers du siècle
on le voit bien déjà par exemple avec le
débat qui a été engagée notamment par la
convention citoyenne pour le climat et
par les écologistes
le débat sur la 5g le débat sur la scène
je ne sais pas c'est pas un choix de la
société
si le choix d'un industriel qui vous
n'avez pas vu de français défilé avec
des pancartes on demande la 5g on
demande la 5g ça induit cette innovation
technique
elle induit un mode de société qui sera
basé sur le pompage de toutes vos
données sur sur la surveillance sur la
consommation d'énergie parce que les
usages vont se multiplier
on ne peut pas dire que cette innovation
là elle constitue le progrès humain
la question personne n'est contre
l'innovation technique mais ce que nous
disons nous les écolos c'est les
écologistes pardon ce que nous disons
c'est que quand il ya une innovation
technologique qui se présentent devant
nous il faut que la société en débattent
et qu'elle évalue les bénéfices et les
risques si elle considère après débat
que les bénéfices sont supérieurs aux
risques
alors on met en oeuvre si vous vous
adressez avec une bande dessinée parce
que je me suis dit c'est plus pour les
jeunes mais pas du tout les jeunes sont
déjà convaincus
ça serait peut-être de mal à vous suivre
alors vous l'avez bien lu c'est à la
fois pour les jeunes et pour les plus
âgés des pas du tout voulu être
didactique et dense est dans cette bd
chacun se fait son idée je pense que
c'est aussi notre rôle d'écologiste de
noeuds de ne pas se comporter comme ceux
qui auraient tout l'art et la science
infuse sur ce qu'il veut sur ce qu'on
doit faire ça s'adresse aux jeunes parce
que raphaël elle a 30 ans elle a été
très elle n'arrêtait pas de me dire mais
c'est la fin du monde noël c'est la fin
du monde
et moi je n'arrêtais pas de lui répéter
mais non c'est pas l'apocalypse parce
que ça c'est une version millénariste et
et qui nous qui nous vitrifie et qui
empêche toute action politique tout
toute action pour sortir de la situation
dans laquelle sonné chez des non c'est
la fin d'un monde à laquelle on est en
train d'assister c'est le coronavirus et
et un jeans de ces perturbations
majeures qui montre que ce monde est
extrêmement vulnérable et fragile et si
on si on dit si on pense à la fin d'un
monde c'est à dire celui qui nous mène
dans le mur et qu'on essaie de mettre
sur eux en place un monde qui soit
vivable pour nous et pour nos enfants
c'est bien et pour les personnes plus
âgées
en effet c'est le croisement de deux
regards celui d'un vieil écolo comme moi
et d'une jeune femme qui découvre en
fait la complexité de ce monde et qui
sort d'une analyse à laquelle on est
trop habitués maintenant d'ailleurs ce
film hold up en est un exemple où le
monde serait binaire ou voyez les
méchants d'un côté et de l'autre
non c'est pas comme ça une dernière
question avant de clore cette interview
de et d'accueillir nos chroniqueurs
forcément politique vous avez été
candidat à la présidentielle 2000 2022
il faudra un candidat écolo quoi qu'il
arrive quoi qu'il en coûte on sait que
jean luc mélenchon ça y est et dans la
course
il m'aura peu sur l'électorat vert j'ai
le sentiment qu'il n'y aura pas
seulement jean luc mélenchon comme
candidat
je pense qu'en effet aujourd'hui on le
voit bien à travers toutes les émissions
qui sont faites ici comme ailleurs que
les rues
l'écologie est centrale et que la
transformation de la société
elle se fera à partir des questions que
pose l'écologie donc on ne peut pas
considérer aujourd'hui que l'écologie
soit subalternes et secondaires dans une
élection aussi importante que l'élection
présidentielle mais je ne pense pas que
ce sera dans des accords entre partis
que les choses se feront
vous voyez bien vous me parliez des
jeunes ces jeunes qui marchent pour le
climat qui font la grève du vendredi
pour le climat qui se mobilisent à
travers des actions il y en a des
milliers l'action ces jeunes là il
n'adhéreront pas europe écologie les
verts n'y a aucun parti et le rôle des
écologistes justement qui pour beaucoup
viennent de la société civile viennent
du terrain viennent de l'engagement
associatif c'est de se réconcilier avec
cette jeunesse là qui en général vote
écolo et de lui démontrer que le
meilleur choix c'est celui de l'écologie
mais moi je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent que si la transformation de
la société doit se faire à partir des
questions que nous posons nous ne
pouvons pas être les seuls à apporter
des réponses parce qu'il y a
il n'y a pas simplement des questions
environnementales écologiques sociales
des questions d'inégalité qui sont
inséparables de la question l'écologie
des questions de démocratie
allez vous rester avec nous noël mamère
je rappelle le titre de votre bd les
terrestres aux éditions du faubourg
avait remarqué que le traitement est
quand même très flashy l'habitat ben
said on parle d'écologie à l'abrasion
on voudrait faire des graphismes un peu
austère ce n'est pas le cas c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est technicolor remercie
vous restez avec nous c'est vendredi et
comme tous les vendredis c'est l'heure
du bloc notes un bloc-notes américain un
bloc-notes internationale et un bloc
notes pour nous faire découvrir un
député autrement on va commencer avec
les états unis à distance avec françois
durpaire bonjour françois maire dont
journal a rappelé avoir suivi de façon
si intense cette élection du 3 novembre
on continue évidemment à suivre les
conséquences de ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis joe biden président élu
quelle est sa stratégie comment va se
passer maintenant cette transition c'est
étrange
oui mais rien on a beaucoup parlé de la
stratégie de sortie de donald trump
en un mot ne pas apparaître comme un
looser et donc jeter le discrédit sur
l'ensemble de l'élection mais on a moins
parlé de la stratégie d'entrée de joe by
d'audimat on la connaît il ya ses
premiers discours depuis quelques heures
on voit à peu près où il veut en venir
rassembler tous les américains autour
d'un ennemi c'est la copie de 19 alors
il n'a pas besoin de dramatiser une
situation qui l'est déjà
je vous donne un seul chiffre depuis
l'élection depuis la semaine dernière
il ya un million de cas supplémentaires
cent mille infection par jour plus du
doublement de cas dans 13 états
américains alors la stratégie de joe
biden il a défini en deux points
la première c'est il faut prendre ça au
sérieux la science la science la science
et puis la deuxième c'est centraliser le
combat vous savez qu'on est dans un pays
les états unis où vous allez dans un
comté vous avez des masques un autre y
en a pas dans un conte et vous avez du
confinement dans un autre vous avez le
couvre feu
lui veut centraliser alors il a perdu
cette première bataille parce que
quelques il ya quelques minutes la les
seize gouverneur républicain les seize
gouverneur rouge dakota du sud oklahoma
j'suis pas tous les citer
eh bien on dit c'est pas la peine de
chercher à faire ça le masque c'est une
liberté individuelle les américains font
ce qu'ils veulent ils veulent le porter
ou pas il n'y a pas de nom c'est la
liberté américaine dont vous voyez on
comprend qu'il ya une couverture celle
de time qui résume vraiment la situation
la nouvelle guerre de sécession
c'est le masque c'est au tour de lakovic
19 donc on a bien compris que il aurait
à lutter contre la copie de 19 mais
aussi contre les virus de la division
merci merci françois incroyable une au
fond un will come the guard sécession à
travers la crise sanitaire qui joue
aujourd'hui cette crise sanitaire c'est
une sorte de répétition générale avant
d'autres effondrements que nous pourrons
connaître avant d'autres perturbations
que nous connaître si nous continuons
sur ce modèle les utopistes ce sont ceux
qui veulent le statu quo les réalistes
ce sont ceux qui veulent changer notre
modèle est ce que vient de montrer
françois est très intéressant parce
qu'on peut leur apporter à ce
qu'explique un un économiste qui
s'appelle eloi laurent qui vient
d'écrire un bouquin sur la question de
la santé qui explique qu'en fait le 21e
siècle
il a commencé le 27 avril qu'en plus de
la moitié de l'humanité a été obligé de
porter un masque et je pense que c'est à
partir de là qu'on verra comment ce
siècle a basculé dans une soie lilas il
aura basculé dans un monde qui deviendra
invivable soit nous aurons tirer un
certain nombre de leçons il a
permettront bien compris il ya plus de
raisons d'espérer que de désespéré dans
l'humanité tir et d'opportunités de 2,7
de cette crise vont faire ravi de vous
retrouver on va parler internationale
avec vous je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste au figaro vous suivez des
questions diplomatiques
alors on va s'intéresser au karabagh
c'est très compliqué de suivre ce qui
s'y passe quelle surprise finalement
c'est la russie qui s'est mêlé de ce
conflit comment interpréter le
cessez-le-feu imposé le 9 novembre
dernier par la russie à l'arménie à
l'azerbaïdjan
alors c'est d'abord le retour des
politiques de puissance elle qui ont
marqué le xxème siècle et que l'europe
pensait
complètement révolue qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en moins de deux mois la russie et
la turquie ont réussi à imposer un
règlement politique et militaire dans le
caucase
là où pendant 30 ans la diplomatie
occidentale s'était cassé les dents
alors la turquie d'abord c'est sa
première véritable victoire militaire
sur le terrain regardez elle récupère du
terrain c'est ce qu'on voit en vert sur
la carte grâce à l'équipement militaire
grâce aux supplétifs syrien face aux
drones qu'elle a pu fournir à
l'azerbaïdjan 7 azerbaïdjan a fait la
différence sur le terrain mais c'est pas
tous en choeur dogan le président turc a
gagné une nouvelle influence sur les
anciennes terres ottomanes du caucase
avec le tampon du kremlin il s'est aussi
offert erdogan un corridor de
circulation jusqu'à la mer caspienne et
jusqu'à l'asie centrale voilà et vous le
dites avec le tampon du kremlin
ça veut dire quoi sur la présence russe
sur le rôle de vladimir poutine dans
cette région c'est un succès pour lui
nous parlait en fait dans cette histoire
la plus grande victoire est la victoire
de la russie
on pensait depuis le début du conflit
que veulent du bed in ear poutine était
absent en fait ils attendaient juste de
saisir l'opportunité pour la transformer
en une victoire personnelle
contrairement aux autres conflits gelés
de l'ancienne union soviétique le
kremlin n'avait jamais réussi à imposer
ces militaires sur le terrain et au
karabagh c'est désormais chose faite
avec le déploiement et là on le voit en
bleu sur la carte d'une force de paix de
200 soldats qui vont redonner à poutine
une influence qu'il était en train de
perdre dans la région mais pour poutine
c'est aussi une victoire politique
puisque en prenant l'ascendant sur les
deux parties au conflit
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie il prouve à
nouveau que la russie est un art en
tornade loeb d'arbitré dans la région et
l'europe
que fait l'europe qu'est ce qu'on fait
nous l'europe l'europe elle ne fait pas
grand chose parce que à part l'arménie
qui est la grande perdante de ce
règlement qui a consacré en fait les
conquêtes militaires de l'azerbaïdjan la
diplomatie occidentale
est resté complètement à côté à côté à
côté de l'histoire
en fait on assiste quasiment au direct
au naufrage du groupe de minsk qui
depuis 1992 et est chargé par l'eau et
c'est eux
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe de essayer de
trouver un accord de paix ce groupe n'a
jamais réussi à faire déboucher les
négociations aujourd'hui il est
complètement marginalisé comme l'est
d'ailleurs la france qui avec la russie
et les etats unis l'un des coprésidents
de ce groupe comme l'est d'ailleurs la
france puisque vladimir poutine quand il
s'est entretenu au téléphone avec
emmanuel macron le 7 novembre dernier
n'a même pas jugé utile de le tenir au
courant de son initiative cela en dit
beaucoup sur le réchauffement des
relations franco russes qui avaient été
proposées par emmanuel macron ça en dit
beaucoup aussi
ça rappelle une règle militaire immuable
c'est quand on est six ils ce sont les
forces c'est quand on tient le terrain
militairement qu'on est cadencé sa
volonté à l'autre fédéric sentiment
vraiment de regarder on a sorti
bordelais on a un sentiment
d'impuissance donc la première leçon à
tirer c'est ce que vient d ne nous est
expliqué c'est que l'europe s'est
montrée totalement incapable tant que
nous n'aurons pas une politique
étrangère commune ne seront pas capables
d'intervenir sur des terrains qui sont
quand même très proches sur des théâtres
qui sont très proches de notre continent
c'est aussi une tragédie bien évidemment
une nouvelle tragédie pour les arméniens
qui se voit amputé d'une partie de leur
territoire qui montre d'ailleurs que
l'après chute du mur de berlin a été
très mal gérée
c'est aussi une reconquête pour la
russie qui revient en force dans le
caucase et pour pour un petit dictateur
qui s'appellait erdogan qui est en train
de reconquérir pied à pied sa présence
dans certain nombre d'endroits et quant
aux envois la carte qui a été montré par
madame la serre alors c'est très
intéressant parce qu'on voit qu'il ya un
as lilly a un accès direct maintenant à
la mer caspienne donc derrière tout cela
il ya des enjeux
très important en matière de d'énergie
avec le gala du grand oléoduc qui doit
passer par la case pro merci merci on va
maintenant terminée cette émission du
vendredi avec une des séquences vous le
savez chers téléspectateurs que
j'affectionne particulièrement
bonsoir camille camille saféris qui nous
est maintenant à distance on vous
revenez quand vous voulez je pense que
vous êtes sur les planches c'est pour ça
que vous n'êtes pas avec nous
aujourd'hui exceptionnellement vous nous
fait découvrir comme ça que se mènent un
député un autre nom avec qui avez-vous
trinquer cette semaine je le dis je le
dis je préviens parce que vous allez
vous avez trinquer avec un député non
masqué on précise que ce sont des
tournages qui ont eu lieu avant leur
confinement à daisy absolument et j'ai
bu l'apéro donc au à la terrasse du café
bourbon avec ugo bernalicis qui est
députée elle est fille du nord idée me
vient d'arras
c'est un jeune député pugnacais très
médiatique qui a sa propre chaîne
youtube avec son programme qui s'appelle
le topo d'hugo et c'est aussi un gamer
il sur twitter il adore jouer il est
connu pour son incroyable énergie son
humour et puis il est très clair sur ses
intentions il voudrait devenir ministre
de l'intérieur voilà tout simplement
c'est son projet alors pour l'instant
ugo bernalicis vous surtout aux députés
normal or c'est difficile de le rester à
l'assemblée par exemple il paraît que
beaucoup de parlementaires ont des
problèmes dans leur couple dès lors
qu'ils sont élus on avait appris avec
stupéfaction une des statistiques delà
des précédentes mandatures qui était de
dire si ce qui fait de bêtises entre 70
et 80% des parlementaires
se séparent pendant la mandature de
leurs compagnes normalement c'est pas
vrai si et du coup mais parce que vous
changer le monde
ouais vous changer le monde vous voyez
d'autres gens vous êtes plus chez vous
êtes à paris c'est comment survivre à ça
c'est de rester comme
comme avant d'avoir été député quoi
c'est à dire de continuer d'essayer de
de se préserver des temps qu'ils soient
similaires à ce qu'on avait avant
donc là vous êtes bien là ouais non mais
là c'est bien aussi mais bon il ya
bistrot et bistrot avec un an 7e
arrondissement d'ailleurs le problème
c'est que passé 20 heures quand la
séance s'est terminée simplement dans le
quartier je voulais sortir alors ugo
bernalicis ils essayent souvent de faire
passer ses idées grâce à des jeux de
mots comme il en a fait la démonstration
dans l'hémicycle en 2018 en se prenant
pour raymond devos benli apprend qu d'un
texte portant sur la limitation de
vitesse à 80 km/heure regardez j'ai bien
vu que vous vouliez affirmé la priorité
à droite
une manière de mettre un frein au
passage à 80 km/heure décidé à
contresens des enjeux bas 10 minutes
j'ai fait dix minutes de discussion
générale
il n'y a pas une phrase lui il n'y a pas
un jeu de mot entre un kilomètre a passé
pas mal ça rigolait ça dépend qui met
auraient globalement horaire aurait aimé
être humoriste non c'est une sphère du
stand-up et oui vous avez essayé ou pas
j'ai fait ça au lycée un petit peu celle
des sketches la fin d'année et donc ça
vous donne des ailes
enfin je suis content quoi non mais
parce que j'aime bien c'est des idées
sur wii ça fait passer des idées et donc
je me dis qu'il faut que la politique
bas ce soit aussi agréable
voilà le mot le one man show alors vous
allez voir que ugo bernalicis est déjà
un imitateur un pas mauvais du tout et
il n'a rien enlevé à envier aux plus
grands sauts seul problème au fond c'est
qu'il n'imite qu'un seul personnage très
bien mais un seul
démonstration écoutez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
on peut dire ce qu'on veut je les ai vus
dans l'hémicycle et que vous prenez la
parole vous critiquer le capitalisme
pour vous mais dans la case extrême
gauche c'est supportable
voilà non c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
non mais c'est pas mal et à la semoy
vous voulez faire du one man oui je fais
que nicolas sarkozy donc ça est ce que
ça peut être un avenir pour vous j'en
sais rien en tout cas moi je sais que
l'humour j'utilise beaucoup et là en
l'occurrence quand j'ai limité nicolas
sarkozy ça a servi parce que c'était un
texte de loi sur la fonction publique
tout le monde se foutait et très peu
d'articles de presse sur le sujet je
fais limitation tout à fait marrer tout
le monde
bîmes plein d'articles de presse la loi
fonction publique moi je resterai donc
donc c'est une arme oui oui et c'est moi
je n'ai pas l'impression d'être
quelqu'un d'autre en faisant ce à quoi
je me force pas serge suis plutôt fier
de me réfréner enfin plupart du temps
merci merci beaucoup camille pour ce
pour ce nouveau portrait on l'est on les
découvre avec vous vraiment différents
merci à vous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine merci isabelle revenait donc
quand vous voulez parce qu'on on y voit
beaucoup plus clair à ce jeu compliqué
du monde merci infiniment noël mamère
verts le pc sur le plateau de lcp celle
week end profitez bien on se retrouve
mardi prochain
[Musique]